oh don't mind me just walking down the
street with my briefcase but you might
notice it's it's made by Honda which
means inside is actually an entire
scooter all you got to do to use it is
just this get
that that this
here comes
out wheel release this comes out put bar
here right
here and that's all there is to do
it so this thing doesn't have the
biggest Motors in the world so you
actually have to push to start the
single motor is in the front so it's
front-wheel drive but once you get it up
to speed it has a 15 mph top speed and
12 mil of range to make sure you get the
top speed you got to double press that
power button to go to mode two then
you're good to go you just give it like
a